Last week, we were in Ephesians 4 and we saw there that life is designed to be lived together in community.
That's the kind of life that is offered to us in Jesus and that is experienced in the life of the church as we learn to follow him together.
So you're right, church isn't an event. It's a family. We need each other.
And let me just say, Lauren, I'm thrilled that you're part of this church family.
We're all the better for it.
Well, let's return to Ephesians chapter 4 this morning.
As we come again to Ephesians chapter 4, we're going to see that the way of Christ is not just a life that is lived together.
We're also going to see that it's a new kind of life altogether.
It's a life that's different to the world around us.
When you put your faith in Jesus and his saving work, you are given a new self, a new you, one that is different to the old you.
We read about this beginning in verse 17.
So let's listen carefully for these are the words of God.
It says, Now this I say and testify in the Lord that you must no longer walk as the Gentiles do in the futility of their minds.
They are darkened in their understanding, alienated from the life of God because of the ignorance that is in them due to their hardness of heart.
They have become callous and have given themselves up to sensuality, greedy to practice every kind of impurity.
But that is not the way you learned Christ.
Assuming that you have heard about him and were taught in him as the truth is in Jesus to put off your old self, which belongs to your former manner of life.
And is corrupt through deceitful desires and to be renewed in the spirit of your minds and to put on the new self created after the likeness of God in true righteousness and holiness.
This is the word of the Lord. Let's pray.
So Father, now as we come to your word, I pray that your spirit would open our eyes that we might behold your glory revealed to us in the face of Jesus.
And as we do, I pray that we would be changed into his image from glory to glory.
We pray all this in his name. Amen.
Well, before we walk through this passage together in Ephesians 4, I'd like to share a quote with you.
And it's from the Incredibles.
The Pixar classic. Last week we looked at the Lion King together. So this week we're going to the Incredibles.
But if you've seen it, you'll know that there's this superhero, Mr. Incredible.
And there's also this little boy who really looks up to the superhero.
And he really wants to be like him and he's called himself, do you remember his name?
Incrediboy.
And Incrediboy wants to grow up to be like Mr. Incredible.
But he's got this propensity towards evil as well.
And one day he is going to grow up as to become a villain.
But you get a kind of glimpse into his darker side when he says something that's pretty profound.
He asked Mr. Incredible a question.
He says this.
He said,
It's interesting.
You always say to be true to yourself. We hear that all the time in society, don't we?
He says,
Well, this morning, Scripture is putting before us two selves.
An old self and a new self.
And the question is, which of these selves will we be true to?
Are we going to live according to the old self and follow the ways of the world?
Or are we going to live according to the new self and follow Christ?
And Paul reminds the Ephesians of the difference between the old self and the new self.
And he calls on them to live in light of the new self that they have been given in Christ.
And so he does so first of all by showing that the new self is different to the old self.
It's different.
So look at it with me together beginning in verse 17.
He says,
All right.
So we saw last week that the first half of the book of Ephesians is all about what we believe.
And the second half is all about how we live as a result of what we believe.
And the word that's used for how we live is our walk.
That's a continuous way of life.
But notice what Paul says about our walk in verse 17.
He talks about how we're no longer to walk or to live as the Gentiles.
Now that's an unusual way of speaking.
It's probably striking to the people who first heard it too.
Because remember, the church is made up of both Jews and Gentiles alike.
Gentiles is just another way of saying people who are not Jewish from other ethnic groups.
So Gentiles don't live like Gentiles.
Kind of confusing.
What's he talking about?
Well, in the Old Testament, God set apart the people of Israel for himself.
And when he did so, he told them they were called to be his holy people.
And they were to live in ways that reflected that.
And he also put the same thing forward negatively.
He says,
Paul picks up on that language and applies it to the church.
So back in chapter one, the book opened by telling us that we were chosen in Christ
that we might be holy.
Right?
The same as God's chosen people before.
We are to be holy.
So here's the bottom line of what Paul is saying.
He's saying the church is to be different to the world.
And he's saying that the church is to be different to the world.
Period.
The way we live our lives should have a distinct quality to it.
We must not walk as the Gentiles, as the world around us, the culture we're in is walking.
One of the ways that crimes are investigated is forensics.
And I don't know how investigators do what they do, but it's amazing.
They might be investigating a crime and they look at DNA
or they look at different evidence that is there at the crime scene.
But another method that's sometimes used is something called forensic gate analysis.
Forensic gate analysis.
So what's that all about?
Well, even if somebody, say they commit a crime and there's a security camera,
but their face isn't in view.
Say they're wearing a mask.
Well, what can happen is the way they walk,
their distinct way of walking can be used to discover who the criminal is
by matching their walk with the person who was caught in the act on the security camera.
So they're analyzing their walk to identify the suspect.
We live in a cultural context where many profess to be Christians,
but they are betrayed by their walk.
So they identify as a Christian.
They may have even made a decision in a church or something in the past to accept Jesus.
But there's nothing in their life today that would indicate that they are actually following Christ.
They're just drifting along with the cultural current of Christianity
as though everything is absolutely fine because our culture tells us it's fine to identify as a Christian.
But to continue to live however you want to live, you do you, right?
But here's what Jesus said in Matthew chapter seven.
He said, Not everyone who says to me, Lord, Lord will enter the kingdom of heaven.
But the one who does the will of my father who was in heaven.
On that day, many will say to me, Lord, do we not prophesy in your name
and cast out demons in your name and do many mighty works in your name.
And then I will declare to them, I never knew you,
depart from me, you workers of lawlessness.
Now for some people, you know, they might genuinely know the Lord
and just that it's just that they have a lot of room to grow.
But I fear that for many, they are actually worshipping a false Christ,
a God that is made in their own image,
that they've just kind of slapped the name Jesus on to rather than following
the real Jesus that is revealed to us in Scripture.
Because the way of Christ is different to the way of the world.
So what is the way of the Gentiles exactly?
What is that walk? What's so bad about it?
Well, Paul goes on to describe the ways of the world and the bankruptcy of it.
And just to forewarn you, he doesn't kind of pull any punches here.
Like let me say a few nice things first and then slip in a little bit that's critical.
But you know, if you're on a canoe heading towards a deadly waterfall that's going to kill you,
you don't need compliments on your canoe of choice or the color it's paying after whatever.
You need to be told of the imminent danger that you are in.
So Paul shows the dire condition of the way of the world.
He speaks about the futility of their minds.
You see that at the end of verse 17.
So the word futility means meaninglessness.
So people are trying to figure out what life is all about on their own,
but their search is coming up empty.
They can't figure it out.
It's like trying to find your way in the dark.
And he speaks about darkness here.
He speaks about ignorance.
So it's good to reason.
And we're invited to use our minds to reason things out.
Of course.
But here's the thing.
You can have the highest IQ.
You can study at the finest of schools.
Read the best books that are out there.
Listen to all the podcasts you want.
But you can't reason your way into the purpose for which you were created.
We can't figure that out on our own.
Our minds alone cannot get us there.
But he doesn't just speak about our thoughts.
This kind of darkness of the mind.
He also speaks about our desires.
Our deceitful desires.
So even though you give a lot of thought to the meaning of life,
you've also got some desires that drive you.
But even if you don't give a lot of thought to the meaning of life,
you never think twice about it.
You still want to feel good.
So wherever you're at in your thinking this morning,
we all want to feel good.
So however rational we think we are,
we are all to one degree or another
following or tempted to follow after our desires.
So there's an ignorance of God,
but there's an also willful moving away from him
and following after our selfish desires instead.
And those selfish desires are seen in our actions, our practices.
There's specific actions that are mentioned here.
It talks about people giving themselves up to sensuality.
So sensuality is often associated with sexual gratification.
But then he goes on to talk about
all kinds of impurities.
So right after that he says,
greedy to practice every kind of impurity.
So it could be a life of unrestrained hedonism that you're drawn to,
or it could be a more respectable version of following after your desire.
But nevertheless, it's your own desires that is driving you forward.
Any number of desires might be on the driver's seat of our hearts.
It could be a desire for pleasure, it could be a desire for comfort,
or a desire for security, or a desire for success or significance.
And our actions then flow from those desires
where we try to fulfill those desires on our own.
Thinking that will fulfill us.
But those desires are deceitful, we read in verse 22.
Jeremiah 17-9 says,
the heart is deceitful above all things and desperately wicked.
Who can know it?
One of the ways our desires deceive us is they over promise and under deliver.
They promise fulfillment, but when we finally get them,
they leave us still hungry for more, disappointed, unfulfilled.
And then we start with those deceitful desires.
We're just convincing ourselves that it's okay, that's just how life is.
And so however rational we think we are,
our desires lead us to convince ourselves that we're going in the right direction
or that it doesn't really matter.
Now initially, following after our selfish desires
could give us a sense of guilt and shame.
We're born with a conscience, a God-given conscience.
And these desires being fulfilled is called impurity.
We might feel the uncleanness when we commit these sins
that are listed out for us in Ephesians.
But something scary can happen over time
is that we can develop a callous heart.
So Paul talks about they have become callous in verse 19.
He talks about the hardness of heart in verse 18.
You can get to the place where you've rationalized,
you follow after your desires,
you've felt the pain and the shame of it in the past,
but now you're numb to it.
You're just at peace with the path you have chosen.
I play the guitar, and there have been seasons
where I've not played the guitar for a long time.
If you've ever started guitar or you haven't played for a long time,
you'll know that when you first start playing, it's painful.
You're putting your fingers on the strings,
you're pushing them down,
and after you've played for a while, you really feel it
because what has to happen is you've got to develop callouses over time
so you no longer feel the pain.
So that's what's going on here with this callousness, this hardness of heart.
You once felt the pain, you don't feel it anymore.
You've given yourself over to those desires.
And now from your perspective, sin isn't the problem.
The problem is those things that keep you from chasing after those desires.
And still, that isn't the worst part.
He speaks of being alienated from the life of God in verse 18.
So the life that we were made for is a life with God.
We were made to know Him, to enjoy Him.
So apart from His light, we're left in darkness.
And apart from His life, we are left with death.
So this is the way of the world.
This is where it leads.
However attractive it looks at the time,
that's what we're looking at in reality.
But we're not just looking at the world here.
This isn't just an out there problem for us to critique the culture.
It's also an in here problem.
It's there so we can all look at our own hearts and ask what way are we following.
I don't know if you've ever come across Alexander Solzhenitsyn's, the Gulag Archipelago,
in that he writes about being in Soviet labor camps and the awful atrocities
that were committed at the time that he saw and experienced firsthand.
But he warns about thinking that things like that happen just because there are exceptionally evil people out there
in the world that are altogether different from the rest of us.
Like I would never commit anything like that.
And he writes this.
He says, oh, if it were all so simple.
If only there were evil people sometimes somewhere rather insidiously committing evil deeds
and it were only necessary to separate them from the rest of us and destroy them.
But then he says this really profound.
He says, but the line dividing good and evil cuts through the heart of every human being.
Who is willing to destroy his own heart?
So this is here so that we can see the condition of our own hearts apart from Christ.
He doesn't just speak about the way of the Gentiles.
He speaks about the old self.
So we have to ask ourselves the question.
Am I still part of that world living according to my own thoughts, my own desires?
Have I been deceiving myself?
If so, what can be done?
Well, the solution that's put before us here is this to put on the new self.
There is an old self.
It's following after the ways of the world.
You put it off, but there is a new self that you're called to put on.
So what does that mean?
What's language that's used for changing clothes?
Over the holidays, the boys and I went with their cousins to a laser tag place,
but it wasn't indoors.
It was all outdoors and it had been raining.
So you can imagine how muddy it was when we got there.
We actually had to sign a waiver before saying that we won't sue anybody if we get hurt.
We also understand that our clothes may very well be completely ruined and written off.
So it lived up to it.
We all came back and we were extremely muddy.
So the first thing we all needed to do was to get a new set of clothes.
We needed to change clothes here and get rid of our old filthy ones.
So that's the language used here.
Put off, put on.
It's language used for changing clothes.
Our old self is utterly ruined.
We need to put it off and put on the new self.
But here's what he's not telling us to do.
We might think, well, maybe he's telling us to stop doing the old stuff
and start doing some new stuff, stop with the bad things,
and start doing some good things.
Like Christianity is, you know, you stop cussing and start praying or something like that.
But he's not telling us that.
He's not telling us to put off our old stuff merely.
He's telling us to put off our old self.
He's not telling us to put on new stuff.
He's telling us to put on a new self entirely.
So the problem with just adding some good things, some religious things to the old self
is still the old self.
It's like, imagine you haven't showered for years
and all of a sudden you go and you change into a new shirt.
That's really not going to change anything.
The problem is much deeper than that.
So our sin has so corrupted us that the kind of surface solution of behavior modification cannot work.
We're alienated from the life of God, dead in our sins.
It's not going to change us to the degree we need to be changed.
You need an entirely new you.
So where are you going to get that?
Where is the new self found?
Well, there's a hint here in verse 20.
He tells the church, he says,
but that is not the way you learned Christ.
So those who have this new self are those who've learned Christ.
The new self that we all need is offered to us in Jesus.
So it's those who've learned Christ to have this new self.
So have you learned Christ is one way of asking it.
Jesus was a historical figure.
You can look at both Christian sources and non-Christian sources that point to the fact that
His existence is a historical reality.
We have these eyewitness accounts for us recorded in scripture that were written in the time
where people who had actually seen Jesus could attest to the truth of what was being written here.
So we need to learn the facts about Jesus as a historical figure.
But notice it doesn't say, but that's not the way you learned about Christ.
He's not just talking about having learned facts about Jesus.
He's talking about learning Him.
So what's he saying there?
Christ isn't just a historical figure.
He is alive.
He is reigning.
He is actively at work in the world by His Spirit.
So learning Christ is coming to know Christ Himself.
So learning Christ means, yes, learning truth about Jesus,
but it's also entering into a living relationship with Jesus.
The new life that we are offered is a life that is vitally connected to His own.
It is through Jesus that we are reunited with the life of God that we are alienated from.
Like God is the source of life.
How do we get back to that?
Jesus reunites us with God.
And so we're given this new life in Him.
So what's that life like?
This life that is given to us in Jesus.
Well, when God created us, He created us.
We're told in Genesis 1 in His likeness, in His image.
Sin, as we've just read about, marred that image.
There was devastating consequences in the world that we read about earlier.
But when Jesus came into the world, He came as the perfect image of God.
He came as a new and better atom, if you will,
who perfectly reflects the likeness of God.
His life was a life of perfect holiness and perfect righteousness.
So in the person of Jesus, we see a new self, a new way of being, a new life.
All right, so we have that.
So the new self is a self that is made in the likeness of Jesus.
So you have in your mind the old self, full of sin, following the ways of the world,
the new self, true righteousness and holiness found in Jesus.
Now take those thoughts and come with me to the cross.
So what do we see happening at the cross?
Here's what Paul says in 2 Corinthians chapter 5 in verse 21.
There he who knew no sin became sin for us,
that we might be made the righteousness of God in him.
So on the cross, Jesus took upon himself our old self, our sin,
all of its corruption and our death.
In Romans 6, we're even told that there our old self is crucified with him.
So he takes our sin.
And here's what is offered to us in Jesus, is his perfect righteousness.
So we're given this new life in Jesus and his perfection, his likeness.
And so the choice is between the two.
Am I going to hold on to my old sin?
Or am I going to receive his righteousness?
Am I going to pay the price for my sin?
Or am I going to say, no, Jesus paid it.
And I receive him in his life by faith.
So these two selves are before us, the old self, the new self.
The one that led to the crucifixion of Jesus.
And the new self that comes through the resurrection of Jesus.
So how do we choose between the two?
What must be a deliberate choice?
When Paul says in verse 22 and verse 23, put off and put on,
it is in a very particular tense, the verb there.
Basically what is happening there, it's a very definite action that has taken place in the past.
So in other words, what he's saying when he says put off the old self and put on the new self,
he's saying there was a time in the past when you learned Christ,
when you heard about him and what he did for you,
and you decided to renounce the old self and receive Jesus by faith.
Now there will be some of you in here who can't look back to a particular time
when you know that was the point in time when that happened for you,
but you know it happened.
You know the old self is gone and you have this new self, praised God.
But you may be here and you're not sure.
And this choice is laid before you, the choice of the old self and the new self.
So will I reject Christ and hold on to my old life?
Or will I embrace Jesus and the life that God offers me in him?
So the choice is before all of us.
And the call here is to put on the new self, to receive Christ by faith.
But also we see that when we embrace Christ, there's that deliberate decision that's made to put off and put on.
You see when we're doing that we're also embracing a new way of life that comes with knowing Jesus.
Right, if he is living and present in our lives, he will change our lives.
Now Paul is mainly writing to people who have put on the new self.
So here's the main thrust of what he's writing here when he's reminding them of putting off the old self and putting on the new one.
Here's what he's saying, you are a new creation, so live as a new creation.
This is who you are.
Now live in light of it.
Be true to your new self, if you will.
You know we've got some newlyweds that are part of the church here.
And before you get married you are two individuals.
And then when you get married you are made one.
You are united together as husband and wife.
But then, I tell you this 16 years on, it takes time to live together as one.
Right, to be living in light of your marital union, this one life you have together.
So it is with Christ.
When you put your faith in him, you are united to him.
And now you must learn to walk in step with him.
And that is an ongoing process.
But the wonderful news is that Christ himself is with you every step of the way by his spirit.
He is the one who is changing us into his lightness.
So what does that look like in practice?
Well we are going to see that over the coming weeks.
Paul is going to get very specific.
But what he tells us here right at the start is that Jesus changes us from the inside out.
We saw it with the ways of the world in our old selves that the problem was internal and that manifested in external ways.
So the same thing is true in how Jesus changes us.
He changes us from the inside out.
So it begins with a renewing of our minds.
It says in verse 23, to be renewed in the spirit of your minds.
So we have to ask ourselves what is shaping my mind?
Is it the culture or is it Christ?
If I'm new in him, what am I allowing to shape my mind?
So in Romans 12, 1 we read, do not be conformed to this world but be transformed by the renewing of your minds.
In Psalm 1, our opening scripture, you can look at it there.
It's laid before us those two paths of life.
But where does it all begin?
It begins by we're not listening to the counsel of the ungodly and walking according to that.
Rather we're delighting in the law of the Lord.
We're listening to God.
So what are we listening to?
What is shaping our minds?
Last week I heard about studies that show the influence of what we listen to at the last part of our day
and the first part of our day can have on our minds and our emotions.
As we sleep and as we wake, like what's set in the trajectory for the day.
And to then hear that and think, well, is it a great pattern of renewing our minds by ending the day,
cuddling up with Netflix and waking first thing in the day and grabbing for the phone and going right into email or whatever it is.
What is going to renew our minds?
All the while as we're hearing all these different voices and we're hearing what's happening in the world around us,
Christ is present and inviting us to be with Him, to hear Him, to speak with Him in prayer, to hear His voice in His Word.
And that's true both in those quiet times with Him when we're cutting off the other voices.
But it's also true that He's present with us throughout the day, calling us to walk with Him.
So it speaks of the renewing of our minds, what are we filling our minds with, what's shaping our thoughts.
But then we also see it leads to the transformation of our lives.
As our minds are renewed, our lives are transformed.
In 2 Corinthians chapter 3, verse 18, we see there that the more we see of Jesus in His Word,
the more we are going to reflect His lightness in our lives.
So this Christ is with us throughout all of life in every decision we face, patiently teaching us and helping us to follow Him.
The Spirit of God is at work, wanting to transform us into His lightness.
So the question is, will we follow Him?
Have we put off the old self and put on the new self?
And then are we looking to Him that we might live out of this new self, live this life He has given us?
Let's pray.
God, I pray that even now we would know Your presence with us here in this stillness.
Lord, I pray that if there are those here who still only have that old self who are in need of this new self,
Lord, I pray that they would receive Christ by faith, that they would put off the old self and receive the new self,
that they would receive the life of Jesus.
Lord, for those who are needing to be renewed and transformed,
Lord, I pray that we too would hear Christ's invitation to come to Him and to learn of Him.
Lord, make Your presence known to us both now and this moment.
Shape us into Your lightness in the weeks and months and years to come.
Before we sing, I'd like for us to just spend a moment with the Lord in prayer.
So whatever He's speaking to you about, come to Him in prayer.
Commit that to Him. Let's pray.